there is a time in every person's life
when drinking water is deadly even as
much as a few ounces is enough to kill
[Music]
the average healthy adult is made up of
55 to 60% water the average baby on the
other hand is roughly 75% water and that
difference is why babies shouldn't drink
water before they're at least 6 months
old not from the tap or a well or a
spring plain water is just plain
off-limits you see everyone's kidneys
have a limit to how much water they can
handle break that limit and the excess
water will back up into your bloodstream
where it dilutes the salt or sodium in
your blood once your blood dips below
zero point four ounces of sodium per
gallon you're at risk of a condition
called hyponatremia it happens when your
cells try to return sodium levels to
normal by absorbing the extra water and
swell up like a water balloon in the
process causing complications like
confusion vomiting and muscle spasms
hyponatremia is common in marathon
runners who drink too much too fast
during a race without also providing
enough sodium to balance out their blood
and if you keep drinking that excess
water will eventually reach the cells in
your brain by this point you have a
dangerous case of water intoxication
which affects roughly 200,000 Americans
each year it occurs when your brain
cells swell which builds up pressure
inside your skull that can lead to
seizures brain damage and in severe
cases death but don't worry dying from
water intoxication is extremely hard for
a fully grown human an adult would have
to drink 2.5 to 5 gallons every few
hours to reach that point but for
newborns it's a different story their
kidneys are about half the size of an
adult's so they can't hold much water to
begin with and it takes just a few
ounces to cause problems on top of that
their kidneys aren't developed enough
yet to properly filter water
so any water that enters their body ends
up in the circulatory system where it
dilutes their blood and increases their
water content by seven to eight percent
but it's not just drinking straight h2o
that poses a threat in fact most cases
of water intoxication in infants don't
even involve a glass of water a common
mistake is when people dilute baby
formula too much by accident or when
parents dunk their infants up and down
in a swimming pool and in the process
the infant gulps in too much water it's
important that if your baby is showing
signs of water intoxication that you
take them to the hospital immediately
where a doctor will likely provide some
form of fluids like intravenous saline
solution to bring the infant sodium
levels up to normal